isla because this is a movie that
involves ghosts and seances
did anything haunted like actually it
wasn't like a haunted set or anything
was it
oh funny you shouldn't mention that
there were a few moments that we thought
that the ghost of new
coward was uh walking among us um one
day
leslie had to play the piano and there
was a door behind me
and it just slammed shut but there was
no wind that day
and then another time during the seance
the lights went out mysteriously and
there was a power
outage which no one could explain we're
all a bit cynical but
maybe noel coward wasn't happy with some
of the changes in the last act
[Laughter]
well i love learning about new things
about um the lovely people who are kind
enough to come here and so
we were gonna play a game with leslie
and isla where i get to know them a
little better in a game called this is
also what i love about people
fun facts
but this one is face the fun facts
because we were gonna do a little
crossover here's how it works the fun
fact is going to appear on the screen
and i don't know if one is about leslie
or one is about isla
and so then i'm gonna guess and then the
person will reveal
it herself and explain is that okay yeah
okay let's see the first fun fact let me
face it
okay i wrote teenage romance novels with
my mom
when i was a teenager
leslie
[Laughter]
yes i did and i had to write a love
scene and my mother may or may not have
pitched a
uh a certain sexual act that i was
unfamiliar with myself
and i had to have my mom explain let's
just say it's not
fun writing sex scenes when you're into
inexperienced teenager
with your mother yeah
i uh i can i can agree with that um
okay let's see the next fun fact
i have bat like hearing ooh
i'm gonna go with isla
no and go just white lobe
it's me i can hear
every little like winter choose food
i can hear like every every little click
of his teeth every time he like
you know does that like opens his mouth
back right
yeah yeah and i'm saying it with a
disgusted look on my face
you know what it's real it can't all be
like oh my god we're married to the most
amazing funny men we need some annoying
chewing here
right i mean we've been together for 25
years so i can hear every little thing
every little like
he flicks his toes when we watch tv and
i can hear him like flicking his
toes um
okay the next fun fact is i ride a
unicycle
i mean i just went immediately to isla
i know i'm wrong again oh my god
leslie i would have never known you
wrote a unicycle
i can ride a unicycle i i
learned when i i got a unicycle when i
was i think
10 or 11 for christmas when and um
i learned to ride i can ride backwards i
don't know if i still can ride backwards
but i can jump off
curbs i can i don't know if i can do
that anymore but i can ride
just to ride a unicycle but i used to be
really good at it
well every time judd starts chewing i
suggest you hop on
and get out of the room right away
okay the next fun fact is i went to
clown school
and can juggle this is a bit of a cheat
i know this about you isla
yeah i i got that one because i knew it
and didn't wait at school where and
where
like somewhere fabulous right paris
in paris i studied with a french clown
called jacques who discovered
comedy de la te from a little italian
village apparently and brought it to
uh out into the world and um actually
sasha studied with a french clown called
philippe golier who studied with le [ __ ]
also so uh
that was something that we have in
common that's so funny
and leslie just rides by an unicycle
and god's just clicking his toes in the
[Applause]
[Laughter]
background
um okay last fun fact my party trick is
a pig noise
[Laughter]
island
oh it's so cute
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right i i think we've come full
circle
and um how perfect is that
i just love getting to hang out with you
guys so thank you for that
thank you thanks for having us drew
thank you leslie mann and isla fisher
blythe spirit
is available now in select theaters and
on digital and
on demand and thank you both
so much